Welcome to the city of the future.
A smart city that knows everything
about you.
From how you like your coffee,
to whether you've broken the law.
Or even if you've grown a beard.
Sound far-fetched?
While the smart city we're about
to tour doesn't exist yet,
all of the parts do.
They're all components
of real projects
happening all over the world.
Put them together and this
is what life may well be like
in the not-too-distant future.
You go to work, your office building
knows exactly who's coming and going
and what they need, thanks to
thousands of inbuilt sensors
collecting data.
The energy efficient building
is designed for your comfort,
reacting to changes in the weather
and the number of people
in the building and adjusting
its climate accordingly.
Wherever you sit, the lighting will
adjust to suit your preferences.
The building will even recall
your regular coffee order
and there's no chance of it
getting your name wrong.
On your way home, you pass lamp posts
laden with sensors and HD cameras
that monitor and record
the world around them 24/7.
Air quality and traffic flow data
tell you the quickest
and cleanest route and alert
emergency services to accidents.
You arrive home, to a nutritious meal
made from locally grown avocados
using hydroponics,
so no need for soil.
Sensors allow urban farmers to make
constant adjustments to temperature,
light and water and monitor
the plant's responses,
so it's easier and cheaper
to grow fresh food in cities.
The level of control smart
technology gives can also be used
to make food tastier.
In Singapore, they've already found a
way to make kale sweeter and softer,
so even the fussiest of eaters
will enjoy their greens.
Your health is flourishing, thanks
to your perfectly balanced diet
but you also regularly update your
doctors using data sent directly
from your smartwatch.
They analyse it and prescribe
personalised drugs and supplements
that are quickly 3D printed
just for you.
Your baby stirs and you're alerted
by its smart blanket.
Reassured that all is well,
child mortality rates are at an
all time low, you go to bed but the
sensors in the street never sleep.
They're busy policing antisocial
behaviour, identifying people smoking
in unauthorised zones or throwing
rubbish from high-rise buildings -
crime rates are negligible.
While much of this might sound pretty
idyllic, it is not without issues.
Smart cities go hand-in-hand with
gathering and storing huge amounts
of personal data
and using it to control city life.
For governments keen to control
certain populations,
this is an incredibly powerful tool.
Every moment of your daily routine
can be tracked, anyone with access
to this data can find out where you
live, where you go every day,
the places you visit at night
and who you're with.
This data can be used by people
with far more nefarious aims
than making you
the perfect soya latte.
You could leave your phone at home,
with an advanced facial recognition
CCTV in the mix, authorities can
easily keep tabs on you.
In places like Xinjiang in China,
where growing a beard can already
get you reported,
this is a frightening prospect.
So are the benefits of a smart city
worth giving up privacy
and freedom for?
Can governments and corporations
be trusted with such huge data sets
on all of us? What happens
if there's a mistake in the system
or you want to overthrow
the system itself?
Whether you think smart technology
means we're sleepwalking
into a dystopian future or enabling
us to live a vastly more convenient
and sustainable lifestyle, it's
coming soon to a city near you.